what happens when the mysterious
machinations of the clockworks meets the
humble tuna fish sandwich five ordinary
tuna sandwiches on white bread were
prepared for testing the first sandwich
was input on the setting rough and
produced a pile of wheat a pile of yeast
a puddle of water and a bloody twitching
segment of tuna mussel the second
sandwich went through the machinery on
the setting course and produced a small
loaf of bread and several chunks of
cooked tuna the next sandwich was placed
in the machine on the setting one to one
and produced a salmon sandwich on rye
bread which a research assistant
promptly ate and described as okay the
next sandwich input on the setting fine
came out on the other side as another
tuna sandwich this time however the
quality of both the tuna and the bread
had significantly improved as well as
its nutrient content the final sandwich
was run through the machine on the
setting very fine the output was a small
loaf of bread baked in the shape of a
hyper-realistic tuna fish when the door
was opened the bread began to move as if
swimming about the room the fish loaf
has escaped custody and is missing
presumed eaten